we can't decouple bitcoin from crypto in
the bitcoin maximalist view of the world
you're committing blasphemy by even
mentioning the word crypto is it
important to look at what else is
happening in the crypto ecosystem i
think it is important to look part of
the bitcoin only meme it's not actually
bitcoin only it's bitcoin in fiat say
that you have a [ __ ] coin exchange we
can't go into them and say you guys are
[ __ ] you're scamming people but also
can you please add lightning no that's
no that's exactly what bitcoiners do
though there are companies that claim to
be bitcoin only but they take user funds
and they store it in a custodian that is
not bitcoin only all right guys bang
bang i've got sergey here with me uh i
thought a great place that we could
start this conversation was around the
importance of a circular economy that
you gave a speech recently on pizza day
and i thought that that specific topic
uh could use some more uh elaboration
and so maybe explain what is the
circular economy and why is it so
important in the context of bitcoin
right
um
well
whatever vision i think that you may
have for for bitcoin for cryptocurrency
yeah
whatever it is
like all of the benefits
of it only really start to materialize
in a big way in a world where
where money circulates within the
internet layer right in a lot of ways uh
today we're in this weird stage where
most or much of the activity happens on
on a regulated exchange that is an
extension of the banks right so it's the
you you're like you're doing the bank
stuff to get your your coins and then
you do your crypto stuff yeah and then
you need the bank to get off yeah which
is very
weird and inconvenient and creates this
hilarious irony of uh
of
the the industry saying [ __ ] the banks
on one hand but on the other hand
uh please give us a bank account right
yeah and uh
and so we're we're always in this uh
we're tension and it's in some ways it's
like if someone invented email today
with all the tech that we have and
people would be like writing emails on
paper and then like snapping a picture
with their iphone and emailing the
picture and printing it on the other
side like it's still useful for some
stuff but like
once it can circulate in the cloud
that's when we really start to see
all of the benefits in in terms of you
know the privacy censorship resistance
flow of money uh flow value all of all
of these things and so
um i think and
what we've been doing at bit refill for
uh
soon eight years now is to try to
further that right
to uh to create a world where people can
be comfortable with keeping their money
in bitcoin and with keeping their money
in the cloud knowing that yeah when
it becomes time for me to buy something
with that money i will be able to do so
um right uh because how what kind of a
shitty internet money
do we have otherwise if you can't buy
stuff with it
so
we kind of like uh the circular economy
obviously is uh uh it requires a full
circle we're part of that you know where
the the chicken side of the chicken and
egg we still need eggs and we still need
ways for people to to get their coins uh
to earn them or whatever um but at least
we provide uh the the leading
to my knowledge in the world place for
people to actually spend the coins so
when we think of this circular economy
um part of it is that the legacy finance
system is a circular economy right if
you take like the dollar based system uh
i can get paid in dollars of saving
dollars i invest in dollars i spend
dollars i pay my taxes in dollars and it
always is uh it kind of circulates
within this dollar-denominated uh system
and and it works now as there is a rise
of we can call the new digital financial
system uh in some way uh we have to rely
on that legacy system bank accounts and
some of these things so there's
connectivity or there's some foundation
that is still being used is the thought
process that eventually these two
systems will completely splinter from
each other and the new digital financial
system will need to stand on its own and
be its own circular economy without any
dependence on the legacy system or is
there a world where we have a circular
economy of you know using bitcoin saving
in bitcoin uh but still there is maybe
some interaction connectivity or
reliance on the legacy financial system
at the same time like how do you see
these two systems interacting with each
other maybe in the steady state you know
two decades from now
it's an excellent question and i think
different people have different views on
that
um
i think that interaction is good um
but
if
if uh if we don't have our own uh the
other the more uh cypherpunky thing to
fall back on yeah then we will always be
in in a problematic situation uh when it
comes to the powers that be we will
always be in the please give us a bank
account phase
of things so in a lot of ways it it has
a lot of benefit uh even for the people
that don't actively use it on a
on a regular basis the big the knowledge
that there is a crypto economy where i
can't spend my coins without you know
going back into
into the traditional system um so
yeah i think there is a
i mean obviously a lot of uh
um overlap and bridge points right and
all of the different uh
exchanges and and so on are are that
um
but yeah i think uh
you know a realistic scenario i mean
look at how i look at all of these
things like how internet technologies
have evolved and at least within my
lifetime uh which is like yeah we have
the internet you know we still have
phones so we can still you know we could
have had this conversation over a phone
call over a traditional phone line but
we choose to do it over the internet
because it's better um so
there's still a postal service even
though you can send an email at
zero cost so
[Music]
it's good to be able to interface with
the old world and i think we will always
need to and the old world is
super entrenched right and
i mean if you look at uh
the history of of bitcoin and
the world
in which bitcoin arose and how it
happened i see it as one of these things
that
um
you know if you've ever worked with with
uh programmers uh there is a
at some point a situation where
programmer gets fed up with a particular
problem and he just codes a massive
detour around it just to like
[ __ ] this thing right and bitcoin is
like that for uh for for money yeah but
that they the nerds coded it all the way
back from from gold level and all the
way up to the payments level and are
trying to build their entirely own
standalone thing and and so from that
perspective yes it takes a lot of time
and obviously the governments that
control the munitions and so on are not
going to be the primary uh allies of
that and probably like the realistic
best case scenario is for them to let it
happen yeah you know the let's say fair
type
type approach that we've seen in many
democratic countries when it comes to
the internet for example what's
fascinating is you're talking about this
workaround this idea of if you want to
actually use software to uh go around a
problem an obstacle uh some sort of
friction uh most people would say cool
let's just go build a payment system
let's go build you know some sort of
financial service and i think maybe in
the fintech sector that's what you see
people trying to do is they're almost
looking at the micro problems and
they're saying hey banks suck or there's
not a lot of good connectivity on the
internet to the banking system let's go
route around that with software but
bitcoin as you mentioned is something
that is a much more ambitious project
it's saying no actually it's not just
the micro problem there's a macro
problem with the money itself and so we
have to go all the way back in the most
first principles approach possible and
rebuild from scratch now when we see
that how much of the the folks and the
companies that are working on the micro
problem how important are they so if
it's things like a stripe or they're
some sort of plaid which is like banking
connectivity those micro solutions that
are definitely improvements to the
legacy financial world
but they still are using the old money
or using some of the old system
are they important as part of this
movement or should every single
developer at those companies kind of
throw their hands up say hey i'm working
on a micro problem let me go and work on
the macro problem which is this bitcoin
project that you know if we really come
at it from a first principle standpoint
is a completely different thing like how
do you think about the maybe value uh
and contribution to pushing forward uh
finance to billions and billions of
people between micro and macro
i think the
the overlap as well like i think at this
point it's
very hard to say where yeah where crypto
ends and fintech begins and so on they
they are the same and that is
the course of it is that eventually
it will emerge entirely in the end yeah
i mean in terms of like companies yeah
i'm i'm a bit old-school in the sense
that i believe that the company's
purpose is to generate revenues
and profits for shareholders
and some kind of benefit to customers
right so um in some cases a company
may see that hey let's go for the easy
route where we can get the instant
traction versus working on this thing
that you know requires massive society
level behavioral change and whatnot
right yeah and so i don't think they
should be blamed for it in any way and i
do think that it is helpful like if we
look at
just the overall trend uh trajectory of
any
money type system you know including
airplane miles and so on is that we're
very clearly on a
on a slope towards things that have
higher liquidity right and whenever
somebody tries to create a thing that
has like bad liquidity like airplane
points then somebody creates a
marketplace
for them right to make them tradeable
for other types of monies and other
things and so on so
and this that's the same that fintech is
right i mean all fintech is just
updating numbers in somebody else's
database right yeah at the end of the
day we don't produce a thing we don't
have factories we just we just connect
apis basically and build uis for these
things and that is of course useful and
i mean uh who who's going to say that uh
the fintech that's used by tens of
millions of people is not useful
obviously it's useful
when you see the circular economy how
important is it that people are able to
convert fiat currencies to take my
dollars and buy bitcoin uh versus maybe
mine bitcoin versus getting paid in
bitcoin right like how important is the
circular economy or what is the
dependence on the insertion point of the
money being paying people directly
versus just simply converting old
currency into the new currency is there
a difference or uh should we really
focus on one or the other
no i think it's all good yeah i mean i
think we've done a pretty good job uh on
the the case where we convert uh other
kinds of money into into bitcoin
um maybe not as much on the uh how to
get paid in it and so on um i mean one
thing that
that we've uh discovered at refill over
the years in terms of like figuring out
like how to market uh
transactional cryptocurrency based
consumer service
is obviously that not all cryptocurrency
uh holders are going to be potential
customers of this
simply due to the fact that they you
know they don't want to spend their
coins they want to save them because the
price might the value might go off yeah
right so what we look at a lot is the
for people who have coins to spend yeah
right and if you just think of looking
coins to spend how can somebody end up
with coins to spend well they maybe
bought bought uh bitcoin uh five years
ago and it went up in value but maybe
they get their paycheck in bitcoin right
so and if you get your paycheck in
bitcoin then you're almost certainly
going to have coins to spend and you're
going to be
a factor in
in this uh
in this economy so i think it is
actually
quite important but uh
as we
discussed the before the call like i'm
not a fan of sort of guilting people
that this is what you should be doing
in order to be to be a good bitcoiner i
think you should do whatever makes sense
for you to live your life in
in
in the best way and i think when it
comes to builders then yes i think it's
important for builders to think about
you know there are
people in the world today that will
gladly take an income
in in bitcoin and who are they
what kind of work do they do how can we
provide a service for them how can we
market it to them and all of these
things i think there's a lot of
opportunity to build things and some of
my favorite projects in the space are
things that are doing exactly that yeah
when uh i think about you you have this
framework that always sticks to the top
of my head which is the difference
between bitcoin the movement and bitcoin
the tool uh you've talked about this uh
during your pizza day talk and and i've
heard you mention it uh in other forms
as well describe a little bit uh kind of
this framework like what is bitcoin the
movement and how does that differentiate
from bitcoin the tool
sure yeah so
when it comes to i mean a very simple
example i mean bitcoin is both right
bitcoin the tool is the thing that you
use you send transactions you you keep
them on a wallet and so on and bitcoin
the movement is you know you participate
in in conferences you listen to podcasts
probably like this
you consume content you learn about it
you're passionate about it you wish to
see it succeed right that is the
movement whereas the the tool is say hey
i need to make a transaction or i need
this guy to pay me i
need to solve this particular problem
and and these are very uh you know in i
think in the beginning uh of the history
of uh of bitcoin they they were very
much the same right it was this hackery
scratch my age type situation and and so
the movement arose among people who are
using
the tool
over the years
more and more people came in because
yeah well they they bought bitcoin and
they want to see
see its value go up so they're like
financially motivated to be and also
they just want to be part of this sort
of revolutionary society level change
right so so we have this this movement
that is very much about a tool uh but
where
it's not necessarily required to use the
tool to be part of the movement right so
i mean a simple example like say name
any tool like scissors you know do you
ever use scissors
yes
do you ever go to conferences about
scissors no why would you even do that
would you listen to a podcast about uh
about scissors no
why right and and so
and that's like the tool attitude it's
just a thing it just solves the thing
that i needed to solve
and
versus
you know the movements where we have all
of these discussions and so on um with
vision ideology and passion and all of
these things and another way of seeing
it is
you know if you want to download let's
take software that's not the
movement connected at least for me like
bittorrent for example say i i want to
download
some piece of legal internet content in
a big file and i need a bittorrent
client i would type into google
bittorrent client and i would get the
first one right yeah and then i would
download my file and i would be done
and i would move on with my life i
wouldn't necessarily engage with
bittorrent twitter uh with whatever
technical discussions uh uh about
different trade-offs of different
solutions and protocols and client
implementations and all these things
that that we we argue about within uh
within the community yeah right and so
and there are plenty of people uh that
are part of
the movement that don't necessarily use
the tools right i mean you can be and
many like most
people that
are part of of the bitcoin movement and
i would say are people that you know hey
i think it's cool i want this to exist
like truly and passionately i want all
of this uh
the the uh censorship resistant money
free flow of value over the internet uh
i want it all i i believe in it and i
want it to exist but you know i get my
paycheck every month uh to my regular
bank account and i just split my apple
pay and it's fine it works and yeah you
know i bought some bitcoin on exchange
and it keeps them on a on a hardware
wallet
that
secured really really well so i can
never get my bitcoins out even if i
really wanted to and so then i'm not
really using uh the tools uh so much but
i'm part of the movement right and and
it's
when you when you interact within the
movement
it's sometimes very easy to forget
that uh people who are part of the
movement are not necessarily users of
the tool yeah right so you you like
easy experiment is like you if you go to
a conference a bitcoin conference and
just stop a random guy and say hey hey
like which brand of bitcoin wallet you
use yeah okay maybe which brand do you
have on your phone and then like when
did you last make a transaction right
and if it's in the conference it's gonna
be like yeah well i bought a t-shirt uh
five minutes ago with satoshi's but
other than that it's been it's been six
months right so so you'll have people
that are members of the movement but not
necessarily users of the tool and then
on the contrary you have a large group
of people that are users of the tool but
don't care about the movement right so
say that you uh you
like recently i heard a story of uh
a developer in in russia that needed to
get paid
for for work and it's impossible to do
so so yeah it's like okay well i'll take
bitcoin and so that's a user right and
uh what is he going to do for
his thing he's going to type in bitcoin
wallet into the app store or into google
or whichever and he's going to download
the first one that looks legit enough
and it's going to get paid and then
maybe he's going to at some point buy
something with it or send it to an
exchange or whatever but
that doesn't necessarily mean that that
person is going to mega engage
with uh
with the community start hanging out on
twitter going to conferences and all of
these things right and so this is kind
of the the distinction and something
that i think was kind of uh non-obvious
at least to us in the beginning because
we spend all of our time hanging out
with people who are part of the movement
and we hang out on twitter
go to conferences all of these things so
you only see the movement
section the movement part of the venn
diagram and you never see the people at
all those who only use it as a tool and
don't couldn't care less about any of
the and the movement of things
and so it's it's a good framework
for i think when building especially
like transactional services to be
mindful of that
you know you have
your friends within the movement
and they're great and they're your
buddies but then you also have your
customers and they might not be part of
the movement they just want to use the
thing for the specific benefit that it
provides to them right but the approach
is very different in how you communicate
with them and so on
what's fascinating about this is you're
essentially uh separating out uh as a
user you could be a passive user or an
active user right it's kind of the way i
think about it and the passive user uh
is the holder and holding is definitely
a use case holding is uh providing you
the value of protecting your purchasing
power and really kind of the store of
value uh um properties that i think
people are very excited about bitcoin
what you're highlighting though is uh
there's a lot of folks not even all
holders are going to be part of the
movement correct correct there's a lot
of people that like all this bitcoin
thing i don't even know what it is i
just buy some and then i hold it in my
charles schwab account and that's it
yeah right and you never see them on
twitter or in a conference or anything
and probably like a big chunk of
bitcoins are being uh hold used by
people like that as well right so it's
not
sort of these things are kind of
orthogonal what i think is interesting
is not all holders are participants in
actively in the bitcoin movement but all
active participants in the movement are
likely holders
right so they at least if you're if
you're participating in the movement and
kind of the the social component to it
you likely at least hold bitcoin but i
think that you're highlighting another
thing which is not all active
participants in the bitcoin movement
are active users of bitcoin from a
transaction standpoint and so
again not all transactional users of
bitcoin are participants in the bitcoin
kind of social movement as well and so
there's almost there's like different
factions now generally they're all
working towards the same goal uh they
are likely aware of each other but i
think what you're really calling out is
hey the people who use bitcoin on a
day-to-day basis but are not
participating in the movement they may
just not care right
the whole idea of like uh uh reinventing
the financial system or any of this like
the big macro uh kind of importance or
or things that get the bitcoin movement
folks excited the everyday user who is
transacting in bitcoin may just be like
look i don't care about any of that
stuff i got to go to work i got to get
paid i got to you know buy food for my
family and like this is the best way to
do it for whatever reason but what i do
think it also brings is the people who
are participating in the movement a lot
of those people are
investors they are entrepreneurs they
are the ones who are trying to build the
infrastructure and services and you're
kind of ringing the bell and say
remember the people at the conference
are not necessarily all of your
customers and actually if you build a
product for the people who aren't at the
conference you may be better off than
just simply building it so that the
person at the conference is like wow
look how slick this is i can now buy
bitcoin you using apple pay or whatever
uh is
yeah and
exactly like that and
yeah
i mean it it it is natural it's just
that it it creates this uh again
that it's like it's a very obvious thing
but then like you spend all of your time
consuming uh consuming content from the
movement and
from the uh the tool people there is
content from the tool people as well but
you never see it and we don't even you
know like hey which wallet should you
use and so on is it fair is it fair to
say that we need both that we need the
people using the tool and we also need
the people in the movement like both of
them are important in order for bitcoin
to be successful or do you think that uh
we have over rotated on either side
of kind of that equation
yes i agree i think both are important
whether or not we've over rotated maybe
i think
at least in the extent of like
what the discourse is about within the
movement and it becomes less and less
about
the use and the discussion about the use
is always about the holding use not so
much about
the transactional use right uh which uh
i think misses a a very big point which
is that
you know a bitcoin that you can't
transact over the internet is is kind of
useless it's even useless as a store of
value like all of this is like this is
satoshi 101 uh sort of uh all of this
stuff was discussed within the first
month of uh
of bitcoin uh if you think of like how
satoshi motivates
why why why bitcoin should have any
value at all it's like yeah well it's
this course resource that you can
teleport over the internet yeah right
and if it had any value at all
then it would be quite useful because i
can buy it here and as you can sell it
there and you can send it over the
internet and that's pretty cool and and
why would it get any value at all well
because it might make sense to get some
in case it catches on right but i mean
that that is the history of a
in one uh one and a half satoshi post
this is the history of
uh
of the of the industry yeah but
sometimes we get and especially like
because
everybody in the movement is a holder
yeah so we we all want to hear things
about uh on some on some level we want
to hear about the impending collapse of
the fiat system uh or you know that the
macro
uh macro environment is such that we
should expect the price of a bitcoin to
be going up it makes us feel good and
it's interesting and it's it's an
interesting topic and so
i think that like a lot of content ends
up being
created
about these things whereas uh some of
the transactional users like yeah but i
don't even use that stuff so why would i
uh why would i uh listen to content
about something that i'm not looking to
use anyway and
so
um
so one of the questions i have is when
you think of bitcoin and you go back to
maybe 2017 uh obviously there was a lot
of people trying to use bitcoin from a
transaction standpoint some of them were
trying to buy it and you know move on
chain between exchanges or some other uh
former fashion and fees exploded upwards
and that was one of the big problems uh
with people saying hey my transaction is
taking too long fees are too high this
is unusable from a transaction
standpoint the critics of bitcoin
pointed to that as a reason why bitcoin
would never work and and uh because we
all you know if you've been around you
you understand kind of how that played
out now today we look and fees on the
layer one are actually incredibly cheap
compared to uh the historical norms one
of the things that the bitcoin community
will point to say oh that's because of
the rise of the lightning network the
lightning network is for you know
smaller transactions it's faster it's
cheaper
i know that you all at bit refill have
spent an enormous amount of time money
and energy uh really investing in the
lightning network and doing the best you
can to see that come to fruition i've
invested in a number of companies that
are either helping on the infrastructure
side that are actually using the
lightning network uh whatever but what
caught me i think a little off guard and
many people off guard was you had a very
sobering talk about the use of the
lightning network and kind of where we
actually are in regards to where you
thought we would be at this point and so
is the lightning network over hyped is
lightning network not actually working
the way that you would expect or is this
just the classic story of hard
technology takes a very long time before
it is used on a global scale this
episode is brought to you by eight sleep
good sleep is a game changer and the
eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine i sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
innate sleep you can go to hsleep.com
pomp today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order
eightsleep.com not only do i sleep on it
every night it literally changed my life
and i begged the founders to let me
invest in the company
eightsleep.com go get yourself an
eight-sleep pod and get a better night
of sleep
i think that some people interpret it in
that way
and the the way that twitter works is
that uh the most extreme version of
something in the most
what you call conflict inciting version
is the one that gets traction so in the
end that's what the message ended up
being even though it wasn't like i was
talking to lightning builders at a
bitcoin enlightening conference yeah you
mean that
is anti-lightning is incorrect
yes
sergey is incredibly bullish in
lightning um i think that
but but also i think that like we
we need to be
with the builders
need to be honest with ourselves with
what's going well what's going badly
what can we do better how can we get it
to grow faster i mean lightning is
growing depending on which metric but
but like a
two to four x every year
that's pretty good right yeah that's
pretty good but uh but also like in the
crypt industry we every once in a while
see things that just like takes [ __ ] off
yeah in a big hockey stake and that
lightning hasn't really done that so
it's somewhere in
in in between i think that the thing
that we need to understand is a lot of
these things and and like how you
describe the 2017 yeah i wouldn't
entirely agree with all of that and i
don't know if we should go into the
details
yeah well i mean in 2017 it was a world
in which
before then transaction fees were
negligible
and so nobody cared about optimizing
anything to save on fees or pe
estimation things like that and so
suddenly there was a boom cycle and
people were sending coins to exchanges
to sell them and there were there was no
optimizations in terms of saving on the
data usage of transaction there was no
optimism like none at all uh
optimizations on like fee estimation and
so on and it created like a big mess
and
what happened after that is that over
the course of some years there's been a
lot of optimization right yeah i think
the biggest optimization that is that
has happened isn't lightning it's not
even segwit it's simply the fact that
centralized exchanges have started
batching their transactions so when you
when you're a big exchange and you have
you know 100 people doing withdrawals
per minute then instead of making 100
transactions you make one transaction
with 100 different outputs and that
saves like you know half
or
actually no it saves
like at scale 90 plus
of the data usage and so a big part of
why you see load
on the mempool being lower is uh
is related to that yeah
i helped create a dashboard called the
transactionfield.info
that tracks a metric called payments
which counts these individual outputs uh
to better uh have a view of like how
many
you know transactions in the in the
sense that people normally understand
not in the bitcoin sense as we call them
payments instead like how many payments
are happening that number is is growing
steadily um but it's not you know
it's less than doubling every year
so it's growing at some
pace uh lightning has a chunk of
on chain traffic that has moved over
but i think that a big
part uh also because of
like all of the events of 2017
being so deeply rooted in the in the
psyche of uh of the bitcoiners and how
we've
uh you know at the time uh
lightning was presented as this uh the
thing that will make it scale so in a
lot of ways it was a political
thing because it was opposed to the
other things that the other camp wanted
to do which was increasing the block
size and stuff like that
uh so
it became the case that lightning is
being marketed primarily to people
within the movement
yeah right and so then it becomes that
the users of lightning are the
intersection
of people who are users of uh users of
bitcoin the tool
and also members of bitcoin the movement
which is definitely a non-zero group and
as we just established it's growing
you know it's more than doubling every
year um so it's definitely growing yeah
but it is in some ways
having trouble reaching the people that
are not
in in the moment because everyone in
lightning is so deep in the movement and
that was kind of the purpose of my talk
is like guys you we're all great but
let's look at the bigger world and
there's a lot of people that might use
our things but never get a chance to
because they never find out that that
they exist because we are so focused to
sort of people that are like us yeah
where in reality many of the people that
are like us in the in in the movement
are actually not users of transactional
bitcoin tools and so like in terms of
like user development like their
feedback is can be counterproductive
yeah right you should talk to people
that are like 100 user demographic and
so that was kind of a little bit what
was the purpose of my talk then and i
think that i'm still incredibly uh
bullish on
on lightning i i still think that it is
uh
you know the technology that
is most likely
to be what brings cryptocurrency to many
people in a in a decentralized way and
it's definitely
far ahead of the equivalent layer two
solutions in the in the ethereum world
yeah i'll i'll say that um
but yeah i think
it's important for us who are building
and lightning i mean lightning by
definition is a transactional tool right
if your your only usage of a bitcoin is
to hold it in a hardware wallet or hold
it in your charles schwab account then
you're not going to be a user of
lightning
by definition yeah right and and some
people might do it as a gimmick like
i'll spin up a node or you know i
hey i heard sergey said on the pumps
podcast uh that uh to be a good bit
corner i should run the lightning notes
i'll do that yeah right yeah so
they do that but it's not natural right
yeah and so
um i i think that that's like the the
important thing is to uh to be mindful
of
the people that
um that do uh use a bitcoin or other
cryptocurrencies uh on a transactional
basis and
again you know the question of like oh
are they using other cryptocurrencies
and [ __ ] coins this and that like look
people who use it as a tool
we've already established like most of
them
couldn't care less about any of the
things that we are arguing over and
which of the coins has the better
decentralization properties or whatever
and they just want to get their thing
done yeah and so
a good example and
that i've brought up is to to look at
the wallets that are being used in in
transactional usage right there's
different ways of getting that
information i think the the fairest one
is to just you know open the app store
on your phone
or the google play store and type in
bitcoin wallets and then you can see
what the algorithm
seems uh has decided is the most likely
that you will download
right
and that is what most people will
download and what most people that
couldn't care less are going to use and
and that paints a clear picture you know
because all of the wallets that we
discuss in the in in the movement in the
community uh they're you know some of
the some of the best ones are there sort
of in the top ten uh at least it's decay
you know but like hey they're not
anywhere near the top three yeah so and
and so that also means even though we've
spent all of this energy on education
and and preaching and explaining and
this is why you should use a wallet
that's open source and this is why you
should care about this security property
or that security power property all of
these things right but again
the people that only want to use it as a
tool they never hear those things yeah
right they don't get exposed to that
they just
typed in bitcoin wallet in the in the
app store and that's that they're done
they they they got their job done yeah
that they wanted to get done you know
they they got paid uh or they made the
transactions they wanted to do and
they're they're done they moved on with
their day you know we're discussing you
know who's who's really a bitcoiner you
know and what are the criterias uh to
fulfill for that but like nobody cares
and and they don't probably identify as
bitcoiners and you know we can argue
should we count them as bitcoins and who
cares it's just words right um
so i think that there's like these
things are
kind of like important to be mindful of
but and then also okay once you picture
and i think you can like to some extent
by seeing a wallet and like maybe some
geographical data and so on you can a
little bit picture
the user right i mean you don't even
need to know their age or gender or
whatever those are like the least
interesting things um you just kind of
like okay it's the user i got the
blockchain.com wallet okay
what's that person like yeah okay
interesting and then you can kind of
like er okay they're in nigeria okay
they kind of like
count backwards a little bit like okay
but how do we reach that user how do we
you know create something that that user
might
think is interesting to use
in a completely transactional non-loving
way yeah right
yeah
uses an excellent word here as like an
opposite to love yeah they're not going
to love bitcoin and i don't think that
necessarily it's a requirement that
everybody in the world what is it eight
billion people should all
love and be passionate about bitcoin i
think most people are going to use it as
a thing
and care about it just as much as you
and i care about scissors you know sales
are great but yeah we go about a day no
scissors conference uh this begs the
question of uh when somebody googles and
uh they go for a bitcoin wallet some
results come up but in order to get
global adoption do we need people to
instead of googling bitcoin wallet
google
payments or uh google something that is
non-bitcoin related and so they don't
even know that they're necessarily using
this new payment network uh they don't
know that they're using a different
asset it's just kind of pushed into the
background and they simply know that
they're using a payments application
that is cheap and fast and it's better
than you know whatever other products
are available to them and i kind of
think of this in the sense of
when i go to a restaurant and i go ahead
and i purchase something i have no clue
are they using the visa network are they
using a different network all i know is
i either give them cash or i give them a
credit card and i'm able to buy what i
want to buy and you know to your point i
don't care what the network is right it
works it did what it needed it to do and
i'm out of there uh how important is it
for people to understand they're using
bitcoin or googling bitcoin wallet
bitcoin payment app something like that
versus just
serving the need and actually them
knowing that it is bitcoin may not be as
helpful as maybe we think it is inside
of the movement
i think it is kind of important because
uh in the beginning of the conversation
you're asking me about like fintechs
that don't start all the way from the
bottom but to start from some part of
the incumbent system and i think like
a general rule
of decentralization let's say is that a
centralized solution will
always be able to do technically
everything that the decentralized can do
but you can also do more things right so
the centralized will always and be
faster and better and from a ux
standpoint right where where
decentralization wins is in the areas
where decentralization shines right so
if you if you don't have access to the
other things for whatever reason there's
a lot of reasons why you might not be
able to use these things as a fallback
rate and so in some ways like ah but you
can use bitcoin it is useful in that
sense um
and
you know the other part it will kind of
happen anyway that we're already seeing
the the challenger banks gradually uh
adding uh bitcoin functionality uh
gradually adding sending receipts and so
on even though like
they too are metrics driven and they see
that most of the users of the bitcoin
functionality just want a number that
goes up in value over time and so we
don't even need to build deposits or
withdrawals and we just need people to
buy it like a stock
um
but but over time
that will change but
but
i think it's still sort of it is
important uh that
that it has
that brand you you can abstract it away
but then you just end up building a new
brand yeah right
so you end up
um for example like if you if you're
watching el salvador where the dominant
wallet is the government wallet called
chibo
and there's people that are like yeah
well we accept chivo here right and
that's maybe an easier message and it
also is
you know the easiest one for 80 of the
people to understand they don't need to
care about what this bitcoin thing is or
or any of that but then you you need to
recreate the brand the the benefit of
bitcoin is that it is a brand it is an
open source thing that people know yeah
just like internet is a brand or the web
or or whatever and so there is
definitely a value in in using that yeah
i think both things like
i don't know man
it's a hard one
yeah it's a hard one and i don't think
there actually is a right answer as much
as uh what i get from your answer being
uh sometimes it's important for the
bitcoin brand and and bitcoin's brand is
an advantage and then other times maybe
uh there's a different brand or it
doesn't matter as much and somebody just
wants to be able to have the
functionality and whether they know it's
bitcoin or not might not be as important
um and so it's kind of a case by case uh
basis but but what i do think is
important is that that violates the
thought process i think of a lot of uh
at least the companies and the
entrepreneurs that i talk to in the
bitcoin community
one of the biggest pieces of feedback
that i constantly tell folks is your
entire marketing message is towards what
you would call the bitcoin movement
folks everything is it's bitcoin use it
because it's bitcoin it's bitcoin it's
bitcoin it's bitcoin and i keep saying
listen if you want mainstream adoption
if you want to get 50 million consumers
using your payments application
there's a lot of people who see that it
says bitcoin and they just scroll to the
next thing right they are not going to
use it because it says bitcoin and so
it's a blessing and a curse in some way
well i mean uh
i don't know if there's people that
would not use something because it has
uh
100
there are people especially in the
developed world who if you just go on
twitter go talk go look at like fintech
twitter
they hate bitcoin they think bitcoin is
the dumbest thing in the world okay so
but by that reasoning you would have
expected cash app to
have declined in user numbers since they
added the bitcoin option like i don't
know not necessarily not necessarily
because i think that most people who use
cash app aren't they don't use the
bitcoin functionality
right that's what i mean so like it's
just a feature right it doesn't hurt
but cash app i don't think like this
cash app is a good example cash app
doesn't present itself in 100 of its
marketing as a bitcoin app what they say
is cash app is a payments application
and oh by the way we have this feature
around bitcoin what i
tried to to get across to a lot of the
founders and entrepreneurs that i talked
to is they show up and on the front of
their slide deck is a bitcoin payment
app and i tell them
they're presenting it to you of course
but but even after i'm an investor i
tell them listen
that is not going to get you tens of
millions of consumers because the people
who don't know about bitcoin or the
people who who are the cash app user who
don't use the bitcoin functionality
you're essentially boxing them out and
so instead if you were able to say hey
we have the cheapest fastest payments
and you don't even talk about bitcoin it
just happens to be the thing you use and
the people who care will go figure out
that bitcoin is the network underneath
it my guess is that you're likely to get
more users on a global basis than
running around saying it's a bitcoin app
because it's all marketing right
absolutely and i mean marketing is one
of these things that is uh
you know because our our our movement is
so tech centric yeah we tend to to
idealize the tech and we always like all
of us are techies in some way yeah
even those who are non-technical are
kind of enthusiastic and we kind of want
to solve all of the problems with tech
yeah right so like people are still
solving the bitcoin scaling problem
but like hey i get news for you the
bitcoin scaling problem was solved in
like five different competing ways in
2018 like move on like bitcoin has a
marketing problem
yes which we need to solve in order to
get to the scaling problem but but i i
think i i digress a little bit yeah i
mean you are absolutely right and this
is because we're part of this movement
we are our friends are in this movement
the people that we interact with are in
this movement and we want their their
love and respect and adoration right we
want them to like us it's a natural
human
instinct and but it's important to be
mindful of whether or not
sort of if your customer base
is 100 within the movement and there's
plenty of businesses that are very
successful that are like that where
they're like no no this is specifically
for bitcoin community members and we're
going to market it by becoming popular
on twitter and that's great you know and
then then everything syncs up yeah but
if you're building something for the
bigger audience well then you need to
figure out how to reach uh the bigger
audience and that is not trivial and
you're probably right that
you know the people that seek out
bitcoin are going to seek out bitcoin
and there's a lot of people that seek
out different properties uh right but
but there's also that
uh
you know some of the properties of
bitcoin are not things that you can
market really well yeah right you like
you make the transaction they didn't
want you to make ah you know don't put
that on your uh app store landing page
um
but
uh but there are plenty of use cases uh
[Music]
that are completely unproblematic like
you know pay anybody in the world you
know or get paid from anybody in the
world like
companies such as ours that have people
i think now in 26 27 countries
like yeah well
figuring out how to pay people with the
local payment system and a lot of their
countries is a lot of
a lot of work it's easier for us to say
look we can pay you in
in bitcoin and you figure out how to
receive it uh it's part of the job is
figure out how to get your paycheck it's
fair enough right yeah and especially if
you if you you happen to live in a
country that's not like one of the
biggest countries in the world it's like
yeah you kind of have to figure out a
little bit how people will be able to
pay you to participate in that in the
global work environments yeah that makes
sense i've heard you a couple of times
say the word crypto i heard you say
ethereum e uh when describing something
else uh you've also made a couple of
comparisons and growth rates between
maybe other areas of the crypto
ecosystem that have exploded and maybe
something in bitcoin's only two to four
x uh in the bitcoin maximalist kind of
most extreme
view of the world you are violating and
you're committing blasphemy by even
mentioning the word crypto ethereum or
anything else
is it important to look at what else is
happening in the crypto ecosystem not
necessarily to go and buy the assets or
to trade them but to understand growth
rates and understand where users are
flowing and what is working and what's
not working from a technical basis or do
you think it's all noise and and uh
instead people should just focus on
bitcoin and not look at anything else
i think it is important to look
and i mean what we've used that
petrified is always to like look at
real transactional metrics because
that's what cares uh what matters for us
right
yeah the thing is that i mean i think
that part of the reason why why
why bitcoiners hate uh altcoins is
because that it's a shadow of a dark
thing that exists within bitcoin like uh
it is the same you know like yeah a lot
of the the a lot of the energy and
bitcoin is this desire to like make uh
make money right now you make an
investment and the number goes up and
suddenly you became richer and that is
you know what what the altcoin community
took and refined and packaged and
iterated on and you know made it made it
pop more
and like in in most cases in scammy ways
so like let me be very clear about that
yeah i'm not recommending uh that you
you
you jump in head first to the shiniest
object um but it does
lead some in some cases um
to to easier and
like
product market fit type
interplays and and i can bring up one
example
um
so
one of the largest crypto wallets by
active users is metamask right which is
uh
which is a wallet that supports erc
tokens and it supports ethereum but also
the the chains that are evm based so
binary smart chain and uh polygon and
some of the others
that are that's why i say
me
um
metamask
has grown in this way
because like in that community the sort
of the thing that you do
is to invest in different assets and
then you you hope that they they go up
in value and then you sell them right
and but you hold those assets within the
wallet
and and so the wallet becomes the center
of interplay yeah and so because
um they managed to package people's
desire uh for number to go up uh with
like a web connected wallet uh they've
seen uh seen traction they they appeal
to this grid
element
that
that makes very successful
fine like we we can argue a lot on
whether or not that's a good thing
whether or not that's desirable or
whatever and but i think we can't argue
about the fact that well it has a lot of
users and and that means that they need
to figure out user experience type type
issues and so even if you want nothing
to do with any uh old coin
cryptocurrency whatever other than
bitcoin it does make sense to to look at
how uh how some of these things have
been solved in in that world
where there is a lot of pressure by
users and
my my attitude with i mean with company
building and product building is that
you don't really know
anything until you expose your product
to users right and so and i believe that
i believe in incremental growth i
believe in finding something that
somebody wants to use
and even in the early imperfect form and
then if they want to use it but
something bugs them then they will
complain
and that complaint is product
development feedback these are the
things to work on and and so things that
are used a lot tend to get their kinks
ironed out
a lot more like a dirt road that is
traveled a lot will be pretty flat
versus a dirt road that gets traveled
rarely
and and so
you you know but it does create this
tension because um on ethical grounds
a lot of big corners don't want to
create speculative tokens because
well that's not what we're about and we
didn't show up here to build uh this uh
decentralized token casino uh type thing
and so we kind of like uh
that's something else yeah
but i think it is important to be
mindful
of
the fact that
a very very large chunk
of
bitcoin users will also use these things
uh and i'm not saying that it's a good
thing that i'm not saying that it's
desirable and so i'm just stating a fact
yeah and so
you can't you know you need to figure
out right um
at which point
it's a little bit like uh you know like
leadership like you you can't
show up to somebody and like you're an
[ __ ] punch them in the face and
believe that they're going to like your
ideology right so
you need to figure out how to
meet people where they are and then you
know figure out how to steer them in the
direction that you would like to steer
them um but i think that it is a bit of
a problem in that
the the bitcoiner ecosystem or part of
it really
has like kind of like isolated itself
and like look we want nothing part of
that and we want to build our entire new
thing uh blank from the start and we
start from the bottom up
um but then in the end it still ends up
like
we can't i think decouple bitcoin from
crypto like uh
i would argue that maybe would have been
desirable to do but if we should have
done that we should have done that in
2013 uh 14.
at this point it's like all of the
infrastructure is the same all of the
yeah
all of the users are the same all of the
most of the investors are the same
and like a lot of the things
are the same and so it becomes really
really painful to the couple and so if
you know we we can't
i mean
if say that you have a company that is
uh uh a [ __ ] coin exchange let's say
to pick the word specifically we can't
go to them and say you guys are [ __ ]
you're scamming people but also can you
please add lightning like
no that's no that's exactly what
bitcoiners do though that is literally
exactly what they do
right but but they yeah and and so
you kind of need to pick one of the two
yes right and some people have
understood that and they're like you
know what fine we don't need to have
lightning and finance
let's build our own uh our own network
it's gonna be better it's gonna have
sharks and lasers and and whatever um
and it again it is growing like uh
the the lightning network currently is
uh multiplying every year uh uh steadily
by any metric so it's not that it's not
working it's just that like if you look
at it from the outside it's like you
have this
massive casino type
galaxy and and this uh small little
solar system and that is
the bitcoin only economy yeah and
like
that's the question is like uh if
if that's desirable well then we need to
figure out but but even then
you know
they do interact via the fiat system
right so the like part of the bitcoin
only mean uh it's not actually bitcoin
only it's bitcoin and fiat
right they don't uh try to distance
themselves from fiat they just want to
distance themselves from from other
things but i think that from the purpose
of
of the vision of a world in which
millions and billions of people uh
interact with money through their wallet
on a daily basis like probably somebody
who currently use this uses this with
ethereum and is easier to convert yeah
than somebody who lives deeply into the
fiat world and wants nothing to do
with anything crypto well take it a step
i'll take it a step further people get
real mad when i say it but there are
companies that claim to be bitcoin only
but they take user funds and they store
it in a custodian that is not bitcoin
only right and so in some way the
bitcoin only company which is now a
marketing message because obviously
they're not bitcoin only is paying
a [ __ ] coin custodian according to their
definition right so like you're
literally supporting message and and
it's successful and
i'm of the school that you know
to some extent like don't hate the
player hate the gate 100
i think that we're in a world where you
know coinbase was very dominant in the
us and now it's being attacked from
multiple directions and one of the
directions is from the uh from the
bitcoin maximalistic side and so it
definitely makes sense to do something
like that um i think it and
from where i can see it's it's working
well but that's the thing is that it's
very hard yeah right to really really
really
distance yourself but maybe it doesn't
matter like in some ways like i think
like i mean i've struggled with this
stuff as well uh quite a bit like i
think i've landed at the point where
yeah but this is like my own i'm not
arguing that other people should have
the same ethic yeah like my ethic is
that like
don't promote
altcoins right yeah i i don't betrayful
doesn't we we never have yeah but yeah
we do acknowledge the fact that there
are people that use these things and if
they choose to use these things to make
cryptocurrency payments uh for real real
world things then we will provide that
service for them uh not to sort of say
that this coin is good this coin is bad
you should invest in this that we don't
promote any investments whatsoever yeah
we're we're a tool
we're a thing
you can use it if you want uh and if you
don't it's fine
what's another good example i think is
take a coin base right and a lot of
people in the bitcoin community have
problems with coinbase or whatever uh
they are responsible for onboarding a
lot of people to bitcoin now do they on
board the most are they still on
boarding as many people as the previous
like there's all these nuances to the
debate but at the end of the day in the
united states
coinbase for a very long time if
somebody said okay i'm finally convinced
whether it was a podcast twitter my
friend i read something in the newspaper
whatever i'm finally convinced to buy
bitcoin they would go to coinbase and
that would be their entry into the world
and so i think that that is hard to kind
of reconcile with the people who are
upset at coinbase for doing whatever um
but but i think it's an interesting data
point another example and again you get
kind of in this world where like
sometimes you don't even have all the
information
but there's a company that helped a
public pension buy bitcoin which sounds
amazing and they say that they are
bitcoin only but then in the
announcement it says that the pension
bought bitcoin and ether
and so
again you're a sister company well well
again like the question becomes like if
that company is the one who helped them
buy ether does that should they then be
blasted for not actually being bitcoin
only or is the thought process hey we
went in we explained to them bitcoin
somebody on the investment team said
okay fine if we're gonna buy bitcoin we
also want to buy this other thing and so
as a necessary component to getting them
to buy bitcoin we help them buy ether as
well
it goes back to kind of like is there a
purity test or is the goal yes other
things will exist and it doesn't mean
you have to promote them it doesn't mean
you have to necessarily push them
forward but you have to at least
understand that pushing bitcoin forward
is not in a vacuum and it doesn't mean
that you have to kill everything else
other things are going to exit like for
whatever reason
gold is still going to be around in 10
years right but i don't see a lot of
people saying let's destroy gold gold is
a scam you know let's go and and uh get
rid of it they may say that it's going
to go down in value they may say it may
get demonetized but that seems like a
very different argument than
uh maybe what's being argued about
everything else and so it begs the
question like is the other stuff and
focusing and attacking all the other
stuff just a distraction from the
ultimate goal of pushing bitcoin
adoption uh kind of forward
today's episode is brought to you by ftx
us they're a safe regulated way to buy
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies they've got
very cheap fees sometimes as much as 85
percent cheaper than their competitors
there's also no minimum fees there's no
withdrawal fees or any other hidden fees
ultimately ftx us is trying to make it
dead simple for you to buy bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they also now have
digital stock trading as well with no
transaction fees and no payment for
order flow all you have to do is go
download the ftx app today from the app
store and use code pop and you'll get
some money back every single time you
trade 10 or more again go download the
ftx app today use code pomp and every
time you trade 10 or more they'll go
ahead and they'll give you some crypto
back the more you trade the more you
earn download the ftx app today
i mean i think your your you're digging
into a very hairy subject here uh that
probably will require several uh
long-form conversations about i mean a
lot of this stuff
goes back to to the history of bitcoin
in the history of altcoins uh things
like pre-mines and so on that have been
seen as unethical because in most cases
uh
vast majority of them it was and of
course
so uh and that's something that's
different from say gold you know gold is
gold it's been gold for thousands of
years so um so it's not that somebody is
peddling you gold that they invented
themselves
yeah
and and i think that there is definitely
you know
i mean you can't blame people for
arguing things according to their ethics
uh right um
some things
are complex right some things are both
good and bad especially companies
usually are
um
and you can definitely you know salute
them when they do something good and
and complain when they do something that
you consider to be bad and just because
somebody did something good in the past
doesn't mean that they get a free pass
to do something that you consider to be
bad either right so it's it's a it's
it's a complex question and i like to
really understand it especially if
you're if you're new into the space that
you really got to like study like the
early days of it and how it evolved and
so on um
at the same time like
maybe the interesting question isn't
isn't that yeah right and i think that
in this time where people are arguing
about words and phrasings and so on
maybe the interesting things like phrase
you your personal mission statement like
yeah for example like my mission
statement is for more people to use
bitcoin yeah or
my mission statement is for
uh
fewer people to use use
altcoins right and maybe both of these
uh
you know there's all of these different
variants and so on that gets
get mixed up yeah right and in a lot of
ways
again some of these things are kind of
outside of our control because of market
dynamics right
i mean uh like finance uh as far as i
know is still the fastest growing
company in the history of companies uh
or at least was in the beginning yeah
and they were that because they were the
the best access point to the crypto
token casino and so
yeah
it's tough you know it's it's very tough
to to argue on sort of
yeah on uh
on moral grounds against market dynamics
and
the fact that humans are
kind of flawed and greedy and just
looking for the the fast way to to get
rich here and you think there's a place
to to explain and argue and here's why i
think this is good here's why i think
this is problematic and i think that
there's a lot of cases where the bitcoin
only uh type movements have actually you
know helped people to to avoid getting
trapped and things so it's it's it's uh
it's complex right uh there's a like to
me i think that for me the interesting
question
is
about transactional use and like i want
more people to transact with bitcoin
like on a regular basis like that's my
personal mission statement
and so
if somebody
chooses to transact with uh with another
cryptocurrency uh that's not uh that's
an opportunity for
you know for achieving the mission
statements
yeah and
probably going on the offense isn't uh
the best way of
of achieving that goal but
people can differ in this and it's a
it's a it's a delicate subject and you
kind of like need to to keep a lot of
things in mind if there was an easy
answer here uh
we would have already seen it like in
the end it's like a political question
yeah you know you should you
conservative or should be liberal or
should you uh austrian economics or
should you keynesian economics like
these are things that people argue about
and have different views on
um
and it's
it's a little tough i think uh to to to
say uh like
i think it's it's more interesting to
approach from
like we're talking before like from
practical from marketing standpoints and
so on like what is uh what is affecting
effective at achieving a certain
a certain goal a certain change that you
want to see
in
in the world
what i appreciate about your viewpoint
is uh just at the onset the world is
complex it's not black and white and
there's lots of nuance uh and actually
two things can be true at the same time
uh or two things can be true at
different times so your comment about a
company who maybe uh people don't like
can do something good and a company that
people do like can do something bad uh
and that's really hard to have that
conversation on twitter and you know 280
characters uh and it's also really hard
uh i think when uh when when the
movement
is uh kind of forcing a certain type of
conversation because it runs at
sometimes counter right you know you can
imagine if everyone really really likes
a company uh within a movement they do
something kind of out of step uh it's
unpopular to say hey actually i don't
agree with that thing or vice versa
right is if everyone rails against a
company in that movement and they do
something good it seems off or it takes
courage at times to say hey that company
that nobody likes actually did something
good and we should celebrate the good
thing they did um but but but it's it's
complex i think to your point and uh uh
unfortunately the internet does not
allow for super nuanced conversations to
allow people to have that usually i i
had someone
proposed to me a theory i forget who was
unfortunately
about like the recent developments of
the past couple of years
that
during the years where where the world
was played by by covet there were no
conferences and so on people weren't
meeting in person
and so conversations uh happened mostly
on on twitter or maybe in longer format
podcasts yeah and
in at least on twitter it's very much so
that you can't like a nuanced
uh
analysis of something is anti-viral like
if you write uh here's some good things
and also some bad things it's gonna go
nowhere and what you should do is
instead make two different tweets right
here's what's great about this thing
what makes me bullish and it's going to
go to the moon in that group and here's
what i hate about that thing and
what sucks about it and you're gonna get
all the haters right um and
both of those messages are gonna go
viral the newest one doesn't um whereas
in in a world where people are meeting
in in person having conversations with
with humans it's quite
like it's easier to establish nuance
it's easier to establish
uh human relationships uh uh
ties like mutual understandings of of
ethics yeah you know like hey if this is
a you know a dude that i've met uh you
know ten times in the ten different
countries or uh over five years uh we've
gone gotten drunk and adventures this
and that like somewhat understand uh
this person and what uh
what he means when he says this and that
even i might not disagree with that and
so on right whereas in a world where
everything happens on twitter everything
is like super polarized and you're evil
here and you're good here but eventually
kind of like uh given the principal that
one strike you're out and everybody ends
up in the
in the
in the evil crowd yeah right and there's
not even like uh there's not you know
like the
yeah the recent uh uprising against the
maximalists but like the maximalists are
not a uniform group they disagree and
fight with each other a lot about all
kinds of stuff and like they're there's
like there wasn't even a successful
attempt at defining what maximalism only
like i know it when i see it and so on
so it's it's tricky and i think that a
lot of newcomers to the space
uh something that people don't always
recognize i think
is that
the crypto space is like
it's it's a web of personal
relationships right and these personal
relationships span across the camps they
really do yeah you know that like yeah
you're gonna see you know uh a guy uh
fight with another guy and they hate
each other and call each other the most
horrible things yeah but you don't know
that you know they have like 200 common
friends and most of them think that both
of them are pretty good guys
right so you you don't see these things
uh if you're just observing from uh from
twitter yeah and you don't sort of uh
until you've hung out in the sort of
speakers uh sessions and see how people
actually like hang out with each other
yeah when it's not you know that every
word that they say is being scrutinized
uh
for for potential heresy but can
actually like talk and like discuss you
know controversial ideas and sometimes
it helps when discussing controversial
ideas it helps to be drunk you know
because then you can always uh like hey
i was just being drunk you know it's the
best defense um
so uh
so so these things uh
like
i think that we kind of like went into
such a direction and so like the
influencers that bubbled up were those
that were like peddling one specific
message over and over and over again
finding a certain demographic and so on
they kind of bubble up to the top
whereas the people that have like
nuanced conversations about uh about
things and okay capable to assessing
from different
perspectives kind of like phase outs
yeah and but now
sort of the world is like waking up
again people are meeting up they're
hanging out and you're like oh yeah did
you also think that that thing was
[ __ ] that is actually in our in
group
yeah me too
let's not tell anyone but we're just
trying to discuss this yeah right
and it's like these conversations are
happening right and these bombs are
forming uh over
uh bombs of people that that know each
other in the physical world and have a
friendship and mutual respect and
appreciation yeah and again these things
are yeah
very hard if you're a newcomer to to
understand and and see
and to assess
yeah and social media is one of these
things where
you know you like
the people that rise are those who focus
on it
professionally or full-time but that's
not necessarily
that doesn't necessarily mean that they
are the ones with the best views uh at
all times
right i mean people
i mean i guess i'm biased but i mean i
like people who build things
yeah and uh
like companies or products or
or whatever and like yeah well if you
spend the all day every day building
stuff you're gonna have less time to
spend on twitter yeah right so those
people's messages get a little bit
um
uh
muzzled down in in such a world
with a few rare
exceptions of people who are like
exceptional speakers and i managed to
get it across i think yeah
i i think it makes a lot of sense when
people listen to this and they get mad
at us for whatever random thing we'll
just tell them that we both were drunk
and it'll be a good excuse
before we before we finish up uh one of
the things i want to talk to you about
was a bit refill's been doing a lot of
work in el salvador and you know
everyone gets all excited about el
salvador uh there's some people who
think it's the greatest thing ever some
people think it's an absolute uh
dictatorship and and not going so hot uh
i'm less concerned about el salvador
itself as much as this idea of the
circular economy and i know that you all
are spending a lot of time one trying to
understand what's happening but also two
uh being helpful maybe you can describe
a little bit as to what work you guys
are doing there and and what you're
seeing that is working and maybe where
you're still seeing obstacles or
challenges as you uh try to help
sure so i mean when all of this ruckus
about the bitcoin law started happening
we kind of had a
several big team discussions and i mean
again our goal is is a world in which
it's as natural to transacting
cryptocurrency as it is to have a
conversation over over a video call yeah
and
if it's so rare to have an environment
where uh where there's a country where
okay there isn't first of all there
isn't a big incumbent payment network
the competition is physical cash uh and
the government is not trying to put
sticks in your wheels but actually uh
you know trying as best as they can to
to help and push
these things uh right so we were like
you know what let's make a make uh
you know visionary strategic uh bet
on this uh we go down to salvador we see
what we can do uh to get a circular
economy going and to get it to spread
right to the mainstream to the people
that
don't necessarily uh participate in the
movement that don't necessarily love
bitcoin or anything like that that just
that might use it as a tool that lets
them live their life in a better way
yeah so we went down there in the in the
fall of uh of last year i guess soon a
year ago and we set up a local
subsidiary and we
we hired uh one person at first and then
uh two more team members flew over
and we set up
a bill payment solution in el salvador
by partnering with a local company that
that does that and
yeah and so
what it achieves is that you can pay
your you know your utilities or your
your mortgage or
yeah your your credit cards or
what have you uh with uh with with
bitcoin yeah on top of many of the other
things that bit refill has which is the
gift cards for for digital goods that is
also very popular and especially games
were very popular among uh the
youngsters in in el salvador
even before we we showed up and made a
made a concerted effort and so what
we're doing there is
again like trying to create a circular
economy like trying to get uh you know
uh thousands uh tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands millions of people
uh to use uh bitcoin on a regular uh
basis uh and we're putting a lot of
energy much more than is appropriate for
a
country that size but like uh what we
say is that it's you know it's as easy
as it's gonna get yeah and it's still
really freaking hard yeah right so uh
the goal is if we figure it out there
then then we will have learnings in a
playbook that we can apply on
on other countries uh that we can use
for for
spreading uh the bitcoin dream outside
of
yeah the core group of
movementarians
and so we've been there
trying to do marketing i mean it's uh i
very much
recommend for for bitcoiners to go down
there themselves i think all of this
becomes a lot more clear it's a great
country uh
there's [ __ ] and surfing and uh
bitcoin stuff and there's
you know even if you don't go during the
time of bitcoin conference there is
always going to be a little bitcoin
meetup going on almost every night of
people who are also there and exploring
and it's like a great hangout so i very
much recommend uh
somebody
planning a vacation to consider going
there
um i think in in practice
i mean we see that it's not so easy
even if
the government is trying to help but the
government is the government and
governments are not usually famous for
being great at pushing technological
innovation on you know towards people
right and so it's it's a little bit
tricky they don't always move in in
startup ways because government's kind
of government
yeah so like the reality is that there
are definitely people that are using
bitcoin uh
even outside of uh
also big convention all of these areas
it's still not that like everybody does
right so even though the law says that
every company it has to accept bitcoin
but most companies don't and they don't
get persecuted for that or or
or anything
but it's kind of like encouraged from uh
from a system level
um but it's still hard like we're still
fighting there against uh
many of the
the classic uh bitcoin issues like we
you know first time uh i heard a taxi
driver there say that yeah i have some
bitcoin in my wallet here that customers
paid me but like i'm not going to buy
anything with them i'm going to save
them in case it goes up in value yeah
right yeah and it was like very like
okay yeah fair enough
this is the same it's the same here as
it is in
anywhere else
with these dynamics and there's also
other dynamics that we're fighting
against i think the biggest one is that
for people that are unbanked which is
like 70 of the population
the notion of money is the notion of
green physical dollar bills that you
carry in in your pockets yeah and and so
switching to a notion of money as being
a number on on your phone uh even more a
weird number with decimals and stuff
yeah but even like just the idea of like
that money is a thing that lives on on
your phone
is is hard for people to trust yeah
because is it real money if i can't feel
it
and so
that's the sort of things that we're up
against there's
certain parts of society that
you know are a little bit wary of
bitcoin because they perceive it as a
government thing
which is a
kind of interesting yeah so they're like
i don't know the government you know
even if we support them who knows what
they might do and so on yeah and so
there's like a big effort
from
uh from companies like like strike and
the bitcoin beach projects and so on to
to promote alternative wallets they're
independent and so on but then again you
have the question of bitcoin brand and
how does bitcoin work and and and all of
these things
yeah that
that make it tricky so
again it's it's one of these things
where
you know when you when you have
something with an exponential growth
and you're in the in the early stages of
it
you can you can make an excellent case
for why it's going insanely great it's
you know it's like uh
5x every year yeah you know and you can
also be like yeah but it's still tiny
you know 99 of society isn't using it
and both of these things can be can be
true so so it depends on kind of like
how you choose to to frame it and
whether or not it's going well uh or not
yeah it's still a massive challenge like
and the companies that are there i know
that they're they're
trying stuff trying marketing trying
business models and schemes and so on
yeah to figure out you know how to get
it into the hands of people and there's
a lot of still a lot of different
uh chicken and egg type
problems uh i'll give you an example i
guess like we're trying to figure out
like how can we get
because el salvador is a country where a
big chunk of the population emigrated
and many of them live in the u.s now
and so like 20 or 30 percent of the
economy is actually remittances which is
uh
immigrants that now live
for example in the u.s sending money
back to their relatives back home yeah
and and so this seems like a pretty
obvious thing
that bitcoin would be very useful for
that
and then
the people who receive it can then use
it to pay their bills or to shop with it
or whatever and it can actually
fuel this uh circular economy because
you'll have people that have coins to
spend but then it turns out that well
it's actually really hard yeah for
salvadoran to buy
bitcoin in the us
because in order to use any of the uh
dominant uh buying buying bitcoin
services you need to have uh
i forget an american social security
number which maybe you don't have and so
then you don't pass the kyc stage and
then you can't actually get bitcoin and
so yeah the only way that remittances i
think maybe someone will correct me on
this are flowing is actually through
like the government chief of wallets
that they put in places in the us where
you can buy bitcoin with cash yeah but
like it's again one of these things
where yeah you know uh
it shows the um the the tension that we
have uh when uh when we don't have a
circular economy and we're kind of tied
to to the current system and the
regulatory framework some things become
hard to do right and i mean the bitcoin
dream is a world where remittances is
not even a thing right we're not here to
fix remittances we're here to get rid of
it to to obsolete that concept and put
it next to long-distance phone calls
on the on the shelf of history
because what do you mean you can't send
money from here to there obviously you
can or you know like hey i get paid here
and i buy pizza there what's
what's problematic with that i mean
that's what we're heading towards uh but
it's hard right and it's hard and the
the companies that are yeah offering by
bitcoin in the us are also struggling
you know to figure out the regulatory
things that they need to be on the right
side of the law and all of
all of these things and so yeah
a lot of the stuff is it's it's yeah
it's a it's not trivial um
i think it is moving in
in a very promising
direction
we're
continuing to
to invest
in our efforts in in el salvador and
doing a lot more uh marketing
experimentation there um where we're
seeing some uh
some progress uh i'm pretty sure that
we're the number one thing that people
buy uh with bitcoin uh in el salvador
just as we are anywhere else in the
world but it's still a
you know a very small uh sliver of of
society that
that uses bitcoin on a on a regular
basis but it is growing uh at a good
pace and uh whether or not we'll be able
to sustain it and how fast it will grow
and that remains to be seen and we're
we're doing everything that we can to
make sure that yeah that we we do grow
in
in
in these ways i guess that's a bit like
uh the real talk uh yeah probably this
is going to get edited out because it
was not bullish enough no no look it
yeah but uh but uh we're having the
numerous conversation here so i'm giving
you the nuanced answer right uh
something's insanely great uh some
things are tricky
it is um uh it is closer to the truth
than the extremes that are presented on
twitter right and the bulls and the
bears both have extremes that are
presented uh and they're both true like
they're both
representations of the same objective
truth like we are somewhere on the early
stage of what might be an exponential
growth
you know
that is where we are yeah
and the the rest is a question of what
kind of glasses you use to to look at it
yeah it's uh
yeah like the old i mean bitcoin is like
that it's the the old elephant meme
right where like five blind guys uh
stand next to an elephant and it's like
this part is rough and this part is
smooth and it's it's pointy whatever
right and so it kind of like he brings
out what whatever it is in you
and i mean there's a lot of things to
discuss obviously about
you know
the politics of salvador i don't think
i'm
i'm
the best person to do so i think it's
been
well discussed on uh on the internet by
other people
and bitcoin isn't part of
politics i think i think most of the
bitcoin people that are in el salvador
are there
for bitcoin and for el salvador rather
than
for the government per se and
maybe
if the government is smart they will see
it that way as well um but again it's
it's it's complex
even the government is not one thing
it's a lot of people that are
interacting in different ways and have
different understandings of things and
so on
i i could not agree more where can we
send people to find you on the internet
or find out more about bit refill
just go to bitrefield.com yeah and uh
or find bittrex on twitter and you can
find me on twitter as well i'm sure
there will be a link in the show notes
yeah and at the sigmon
awesome sergey listen thank you so much
for uh for taking the time to do this i
i really enjoyed it and i think uh you
know
your nuanced view uh and kind of what i
perceive as your constant pursuit of uh
of the ground truth is uh uh is
admirable and i think important um and
uh you know it's fun to screw around on
the internet but at the end of the day
we do have to build products we do have
to to continue to improve the tools uh
so that people continue to us use this
stuff so i appreciate uh not only one
your your and your team's contribution
in terms of doing that but also uh uh
your ability to uh just kind of remind
people hey the tool is important and uh
the movement's important too but uh but
we do need to build stuff and uh
i think that a lot of people appreciate
that message so uh so thanks so much for
sharing it thank you so much
thanks so much for the opportunity it's
a lot of fun all right we'll definitely
do it again in the future